Sandra Nevada author of super hubs page
13 of your book you write this serial
entrepreneur super investor and
billionaire Nick Hanauer has cautioned
his fellow zillionaires that the
pitchforks are coming can you tell us
whether you agree with that or why do
you think that's true
yes I think the pitchforks have been
coming for a long time I've actually
been concerned since 2007 which is why I
called my company beyond global because
I thought that we'd see a huge backlash
that would be global in nature and very
far-reaching and actually result in a
scaling back not just of the financial
the influence of the financial
institutions but of globalization in
general what do you do for a living I
consult about what about micro economic
couldn't things what does that mean if
why would I probably wouldn't hire you
but who would hire you private banks
family offices and it gives them an
outside perspective and connects the
dots my perspective would be an outside
perspective because what I also touch
upon in the book is the echo chamber
that many CEOs operate in and I used to
work with Nouriel Roubini who's an
economist and he would also give his
perspective and his analysis and there
is value in an outside perspective
because I like I say in the book if
you're surrounded by like-minded people
who all think the same thing have the
same background
it becomes an echo chamber that results
in analysis paralysis and basically the
situation that we find ourselves in
right now can you tell us the story
about Bill Gross the story in terms of
pemko the story you tell in the book but
he what's he do what's you know and why
did that get your attention to put him
in the book well because I tried to add
one the book is about networks and the
super haps and super hubs are the nodes
in the network that are in the center
and they're in the center because they
have the most connections to any other
node in the system and so I point out
people like George Soros or Jamie Dimon
or Bill Gross
because they're connected to everything
they have the greatest influence on the
system and I also tried to describe how
these people get there what propels them
to the center of the network and part of
it is their personalities and their
personalities in general deviate a
little from the norm they're very
extreme in many different respects and I
talk about Bill Gross in that respect
and that he's very single-minded and
very focused and you know very conscious
of his power and I basically describe
how it went he was very has been very
influential has attracted a lot of money
and even when he left PIMCO because he
clashed with staff he immediately
attracted billions to follow him what is
what is pemko for folks that don't
invest and hear about it but they don't
know what it does
pemko is a giant bond investor they
invest billions in the global bond
markets and it now belongs to aliens who
do they relate to in other words who do
they do business with they do business
they manage money for other people
meaning institutional investors so it
could be your pension fund my insurance
company that collect all our monies and
then they have to invest them with
institutional investors because they
need to pay us on a regular basis a
pension funds on a monthly basis or the
insurance company needs to make a payout
for something that they're liable for
and so they need to generate income and
that's why they invest in with all kinds
of different institutional investors so
they manage their money for them go back
to super you talked about nodes but
super hubs is that a person well I use
network theory and apply it to the
financial system in our society but
network theory is assigns relatively new
science it ties into complexity science
network theory is sort of the
architecture of complex system and what
I say in the book is that the financial
system is a complex self-organizing
system where the people in the center
those super hubs have the most influence
over the system but they have no control
over it so to answer your question
other examples for other complex systems
would be our brain or an ant colony
where for instance in our brain the
synopsis all cooperate but there's no
you know major the cell that's the boss
that's telling the other cells what to
do so we have super hubs in our brain or
the ecology would be another example
because notes prefer to attach to other
notes which already have many
connections because in nature or in our
lives those who have the most
connections that increases the chance of
our survival
how smarter these people that manage all
this money exceedingly smart they have a
bird's-eye view over the system and
because they understand the system in
its complexity and in its entirety that
enables them to basically put themselves
in the best position well I'm gonna ask
you about some personalities a Dick Fuld
who used to run Lehman Brothers I want
to show you just a short clip here and
then if he was so smart why did that
company go out of business and let's
that's watching Lehman's demise was
brought on by many destabilizing factors
the collapse of the real estate market
naked short attacks false rumors
widening spreads on credit default swaps
rating agency downgrades a loss of
confidence by clients and counterparties
and buyers sitting on the sidelines
waiting for an assisted deal it is too
late for Lehman Brothers but the
government has now been forced to
dramatically change the rules and
provide substantial support to other
institutions and he blamed everybody but
himself
is that fair assessment well what I say
is everybody in that sphere at the very
top they're all extremely smart and
they're all very industrious but what
really sets them apart usually is their
networks and bill he fold was a little
bit of an outlier in that he was not a
people person he came from a slightly
different background he be even
physically isolated himself within the
bank and cut himself up from off from
vital information flows meaning from
while other Wall Street super hubs are
the Wall Street CEO
the market in general but also within
the company so he landed in essence in
one of those echo chambers where he just
surrounded himself with yes-men people
were exactly like him and they figured
out very quickly that was easier to get
along with him if they didn't object to
anything and so that basically
eventually became his downfall because
he wasn't plugged in anymore
what would have happened if a lot of
people liked him back during the 2008
crash would they have bailed out Lehman
Brothers if they liked him I think it
could have made a little bit of a
difference that's very hard to say but
apparently he antagonized or had
antagonized hank paulson and wasn't on
the best terms with him to Paulson's
credit he tried to help Lehman it wasn't
you know it wasn't purely personal but I
do think that personal connections in
the end can tip the scale and you know
supposedly President Bush didn't even
take his call
so I mean sometimes these personal
relationships make a difference let me
show you a short video clip of your
you're not with Nouriel Roubini anymore
but I wanted to show him then tell me
about him and how much work you did for
him there is already a backlash because
of this financial crisis against market
economies against free trade agreement
capital flows against trade
liberalisation and I think that part of
the backlash is because the economic and
social cost of this crisis and becomes
so large and excessive that there is
rightly so a populist backlash against
them that was back in 2010 and really
haven't seen as much of him as we used
to but he was telling us that things
were not going to go too well back
before the crisis why did he no I think
interestingly and I also at the time had
you know conversations with George Soros
and myself included we are all people
who we were not from here we had kind of
a transatlantic perspective and more of
an outsider's perspective and I think
sometimes that can give you a leg up and
I think Nouriel was is a very
independent thinker and he's not afraid
of controversy and I think it takes
great courage to stick your neck out and
go against consent
especially in 2007 for instance I
remember Davos that year in January
Nouriel was in the absolute minority the
prevailing opinion was that we have
another Goldilocks year
nobody really foresaw the crisis and
also mentioned in the book that Ben
Bernanke mentioned in his book that he's
speaking again of the echo chamber had
no clue of the impending crisis because
he wasn't really aware of the huge
vehicles as PVS that were out there on
all the toxic papers that were in there
so it's quite amazing you've got a law
degree from Fordham yes an undergraduate
degree in Germany no I'm I have a law
degree in Germany and here and I'm
admitted in both countries to practice
where are you from originally Germany
when did you come to the United States
16 years ago why for a job offer and
when did you grow up learning English no
I actually got English late I started
with Latin my parents made me start with
Latin when I was 10 years old and I go
to English when I was 13 what your
parents do my father ran his own
companies from Iran and came to Germany
to study and he had a foam company and
my mother was a housewife when did you
get interested in money i I've never
really been per se interested in money I
would say more generally business why
what what got you interested in because
business is entrepreneurial it's
international and you interact with
interesting people so again I go back to
what you do for a living if I say I want
to hire you
what's the what's the first thing you do
for somebody when they walk into a large
company it's very individual I just deal
with a handful of clients for instance I
deal with family offices and what I've
done for them is established a platform
for them what actually I also mentioned
in the book and also the importance of
networks can only thrive on platforms
and the way we organize our society is
through networks we have become the
prevailing species on this planet
through our cooperation and networks so
for instance family offices tend to be
slightly isolated from a family office
is
to explain if a family it makes a lot of
money because they have a company or
they sell a company or it could be new
money old money could be third
generation could be a family with five
members or a family with a thousand
members of Dell with you know all kinds
of different family offices so they make
so much money if it's in excess of 500
million dollars it becomes worth
establishing your own investment company
then you don't have to deal with bank
fees and you have confidentiality and a
whole number of other advantages but
these family offices they're not from
the financial industry and often they're
come from small cities or they're quite
isolated and I help them to come
together on a platform where they could
exchange their expertise globally so I
was essentially brought on because of my
global contacts you open the book by
talking about the trip to Davos
what is Davos where is it what's it look
like and why did you open the book that
way yes Davos is the is a small ski
village in Switzerland where the world's
Economic Forum has been taking place for
over 40 years
the World Economic Forum essentially has
been a private sort of conference
endeavor but it just recently been
elevated to the status of an institution
akin to the Red Cross for public-private
partnership and every year in excess of
2,500 people come together their CEOs
world leaders decision-makers really
from all countries but not just them all
so young global leaders people from you
know philanthropic institutions that
don't have to pay a fee so it's a it's a
why it makes of people come together
there to discuss global problems and
find solutions what's it cost to go it's
expensive I think I have the prices in
the book I think for a company goes to
500,000 Swiss francs so what happens
when you go there what was it like or
how often have you been I've been ten
years in a row No so what do you do when
you get there I well essentially you
attend panels and workshops and you
interact with people and you speak and
it's kind of amorphous and everybody can
do whatever they want you can sit and
work
chops all day long or panels and
discussions but many people use these
meetings for bilaterals or side meetings
it's very efficient if four days of
doubles can spare you three months of
travel so you get to see everybody in
it's it's very good to take the
temperature of the worlds which the
first year I attended was 2007
I actually was already very worried I
could tell somebody something was in the
pipeline something was brewing and I
think it's because of my background and
structured finance a little bit then I
knew something was off but as of at the
latest 2009 on everybody was always
worried there was doom and gloom mood
the last two years have been better but
this year was already very people were
very concerned again I want to put on
the screen
you don't write about this but I want to
get your perspective on it and the
between 2008 and 2015
this government find a whole bunch of
banks a lot of money if we see it on the
screen there I'll show you the Bank of
America and we'll find a 80 billion
dollars JPMorgan 39 billion
Lloyd's of London twenty billion
Barclays 14 RBS eleven then there more
Wells Fargo ten billion you can see down
the list why why was no-one ever in your
opinion indicted for criminal activity
and why is it that all these banks
refined this kind of money and the
people that ran them never got a hit on
their salaries and their stock stayed up
and I can go on and on it to the outside
world it's hard to figure this well I
have no good explanation or an excuse
for it I don't think it's right I think
it's the way that the system is set up
and then there are such phenomena as
regulatory capture psychological capture
the revolving door that aggravates the
problem meaning people who go back
between the private and public sector
back and forth there are so many
examples Bob Rubin Hank Paulson
just I have several pages in the book on
that so and I think also often times the
CEO at the top doesn't explicitly tell
people to do something that is illegal
but he just sort of sets goals and then
people feel pressure and then they sort
of make it happen on the on lower levels
and that somehow in that whole process
accountability gets lost what's your
reaction when you hear somebody that's
worth a lot of money say they're gonna
give half of it away before they die I
think it's very good but I think it were
better if the system were set up
differently so that they wouldn't make
all this money and then have the power
to decide who gets it but that it would
be distributed more evenly right from
the get-go well if you don't have any
deductions you can pay as much as if you
make a lot of money fifty percent of
your money a year and the taxes and a
guy like Warren Buffett who's worth I
don't know 50 60 billion dollars paid
seventeen percent last year and so if he
gives it all away isn't he just paying
the government what he should have paid
him in the first place I guess you could
argue that but I still think it would be
a better way and more empowering for
people and you would seem fairer if
people made more money because now we
have a situation where CEOs make 300
times more than what the average worker
makes and I think this has contributed
to the pitchforks coming that people are
upset and that we're seeing increasing
polarization and populism all over the
world when did you think this book was
worth spending four years on and what
would what led up to that and who do you
who's the audience for this book what
led to this book was pure ignorance I
had no idea what it would entail I just
started writing and then I kind of
became the longer I worked on it the
more passionate I became and I think
it's primarily geared at the general
public I tried to you know reduce I mean
I was it was rejected a couple of times
also because it was too academic as I
was fascinated with network theory and
all of that and publishers said this is
very interesting but nobody's going to
buy it you have to insert stories so I
try to make it more tangible
and as interesting as possible it's not
a bank bashing book I'm not terribly
critical I disclose this in the very
beginning because it's sort of my world
I just wanted to give a sort of neutral
perspective so people would have the
power to make their own decisions let's
let's go to page two thousand two
thousand two hundred and seven and I'll
read it and get you to talk more about
it as we mingle during the cocktail hour
I checked the place cards to my delight
I saw that I would be seated by John
Merriweather the John Merriweather who
had made Wall Street history in light of
his colorful background I expected a
charismatic and swashbuckling
personality who had mesmerized us with
fascinating anecdotes yet contrary to my
expectations and walked a slight
unimposing in shy man and then you go on
to talk more about him who's John
Merriweather John Merriweather started
long term capital which decade before
the crisis I think it was was kind of a
precursor to the 2007 crisis because
with this fund that he started he hired
two Nobel laureates to work with him
many Wall Street luminaries and they
started this shop and they attracted
unbelievable amounts of money that they
managed and they designed quantitative
computer models with which they managed
the money and the problem with computer
models as we've seen in the crisis is
that all data points come from the past
and all experiences that you factor in
and as Steve Jobs said you can only
connect the you can only connect dots
for the past not going forward so what
they didn't proceed in there you know
being genius was that all asset classes
would become correlated and so when the
Russia crisis happened the market fell
and basically long-term capital was the
first big fund that had to be bailed out
by a concerted effort of Wall Street
because it could have unraveled Wall
Street at the time so with John
Meriwether one of the super hubs John
Meriwether was certainly one of the
super hubs and then what was amazing is
that he tried to come Beck's and people
would still give him money because he is
very
but it's track record was a little bit
um was not the best anymore but people
at I say it's the halo effect once
people have this reputation and are
considered on Wall Street to be
ingenious everybody buys into it is
there a way you can characterize what a
Super Hub is like meaning I'm talking
about the people what would you say
about most of them well almost all of
them are male as we see on Wall Street
there's one woman abigail Johnson who
came into our position because her
father retired from fidelity it's the
fidelity family and on a butene of
Santander in in Europe because her
father passed away so we have two women
because of their fathers they came into
their positions so it's almost all male
and white they are you know they like to
have power they strive strive for power
alpha personalities curious interested
in learning expanding their horizons
very good at building relationships and
networks can you trust them I mean it
depends on where you're coming from
personally I would say yes because it's
a precondition of a good relationships
that you're trustworthy because
otherwise people you know won't enter
into transactions with you do they
deserve the kind of money they make
everything is relative I argue in my
book that I don't think so then it
should be somewhat in relation to the
wealth to the value that you contribute
to society and I compare it to doctors
for instance they don't get a bonus
because the patient doesn't die or
because he you know survives the surgery
or policemen who put their lives on the
line and they make a fraction of what
Wall Streeters make so but I think it's
a reflection of the value that we as a
society have how much did you have to
tiptoe around the personalities and this
because of the kind of work you do and
that you might work for him some day I
didn't toll at all I didn't include any
nasty gossip that I may have become
aware of or any non-public information
with which I was entrusted
is somewhat critical here and there but
nobody has complained so far I want to
show you some more video here is a man
that is seen going into the Trump Tower
during the transition period his name is
Anthony scar Moochie let's watch him and
ask you about him we're just working
super hard up there we've got a real
executive search process in place to
help the president-elect and the vice
president pick pick the people and what
he's really searching for his
like-minded people that want to serve
the American people
subordinate their egos to the collective
body of the team and really put the
American people's interests first
what's he do other than be an aide to
Donald Trump he started a money managing
company skybridge capital which he just
sold and how big a business was it and
as he is he just going to be an aide to
Donald Trump it I think he managed up to
13 billion dollars in his fund as a fund
of fund business he just sold it he was
supposed to be the advisor to the
president as I understand it it's
currently in dispute and he may become
an ambassador here's another one this is
Jamie Dimon we see him a lot coming down
and testifying let's watch this in
hindsight the traders did not have the
requisite understanding of the risk they
took CIO particularly synthetic credit
portfolio should have gotten more
scrutiny from both senior management and
the firm-wide risk control function tell
us about him well Jamie is sort of the
unofficial diplomat for Wall Street here
in Washington
he's been the absolute alpha male
amongst all these alpha males he hasn't
backed down by all accounts he's done a
good job I mean it's a hard job and yeah
I don't know well but again tell us why
JPMorgan was fined forty billion dollars
and that's several different reasons in
there but how do you then maintain your
CEO ship and you get rewarded and the
stock keeps going up it explain it to
the average person if they did the same
thing
they would be out of money they'd be
bankrupt they wouldn't have anything
yeah I mean it's capitalism without
bankruptcy it's like religion without
hell sort of there is no accountability
and these big banks have basically an
insurance policy from the taxpayer and
after the crisis Nouriel Roubini and
others including myself have argued that
big banks shouldn't be allowed to become
so humongous but they should be made
smaller through loss and whatever not be
broken apart but what we have now is
that big banks are bigger than they've
been ever before and they're more
powerful and they have a direct channel
in Washington we see the Advisory
Council that President Trump now has
with all the CEOs and of course you know
they exercise their influence do you
remember why you used the two words
slimy weasels in your book yes because I
quoted Ray Dalio why did you quote him
what was the purpose Ray Dalio is also
an investment manager I think he runs
the largest hedge fund in the world and
he wrote a book for I think it was
originally for his employees and it was
a it was an expression that he used and
he was when the press got wind of it he
was criticized by said firstly for it
and ridiculed also what you say here
that in his book principles in which
managers who talked about subordinates
behind their backs are called slimy
weasel right you also say that DeLeo
himself deluded emotionally illiterate
and he's deluded emotionally the quote
Financial Times emotionally illiterate
and weird before I ask you about am I
just going to read more what you wrote
in your book about his fund according to
one ex-employee everyone gains ten
pounds in the first year due to the
great cafeteria and long hours in an
isolated environment all emails are
monitored and conversation as well as
phone calls are taped except for the
most personal ones everyone couldn't
listen to the recordings
which are stored in a quote transparency
library unquote overhead cameras
document employees every move
quote issue logs on unquote and
believability matrixes track mistakes
and gossip is strictly prohibited is
that you is that talking about what he
does in his company yes I cite The Wall
Street Journal and Financial Times it's
their judgment I've also spoken to a
couple of people who have worked there I
understand I just recently heard that
mr. Dalio complained about this
characterization of the Wall Street
Journal and I probably the the facts are
probably correct he would I presume beg
to differ with the impression this
evokes but I guess the point is that
it's a hyper transparent culture with
great control but it serves to you know
serves to like it's like a major brain
storming operation to harvest the
breasts the best thoughts of everyone
why would anybody want to work in a
place that they monitor their emails
they listen to their phone calls and the
what's this thing about a transparency
library where you can listen to the
phone calls I'm in detail I shouldn't
really speak to it because mr. Dahlia
would be best equipped to talk about it
but and this is a very extreme example
of Wall Street culture and maybe that's
the reason why I mention it because it's
the epitome of a military kind of
structure where you have to serve the
cause and I go into this in other parts
of the book that you know you stayed
24/7 you have you brag with your
all-nighters this is how culture of
glorifying not needing any sleep and
always being at the disposal of your
boss and that's been the culture there
for a long time and part of the reason
why Wall Streeters make so much money or
justify the money that they make how do
these people live what kind of world are
they live in what kind of houses do they
live in where do they live
well on average the lifespan of an
investment banker is relatively short in
that profession I think on average 7 or
9 years because it's so stressful most
people bow out but the super hubs have
extreme stamina and mental strength
and either they're originally equipped
for this position to get to the very top
or they adapt along the way so yes they
have very nice lifestyles of course they
have you know tons of money but I do
think that the super helps to actually
make it to the very top and stay there
are not primarily motivated by money
they want to have standing and status
they want to be respected and want to
have power and not even in a negative
sense power in its most basic level is
to have self-control to be in control of
your life and that science has proven
makes people happy what do you think of
the charity world you write about it in
the book and once you've made a lot of
money and all of a sudden you get
interested in charity what do you think
of that world I've thought a lot about
it whether it's hypocritical and just
serves for these people to promote their
egos but I think in the end of it serves
a good purpose it's worth it and so what
if they get press coverage and you know
positive reviews I think that's fine and
I think it's a good self reinforcing
mechanism because if you solicit money
from people and then they are also
obliged to donate to your causes and so
donations have spiked since the crisis
again revolution higher taxes or Wars
what are we most likely to see here in
this country
I I call it an evolving evolution
because it's been in the pipeline for a
long time and I don't think it's just in
this country we're seeing it in Europe
we're seeing it in the Middle East and I
think it's these phenomena concurrent
phenomena kind of exacerbate each other
you know so now we have Donald Trump as
president and the things that he's doing
they are having consequences in Europe
for instance I mean it all feeds through
the system by what I say is that you
know okay so finance is a complex
self-organizing system and the super
hubs have disabled corrective mechanisms
for a very long time because every
system over a while becomes more
homogeneous and connections grow and
then systems become skewed and that's
one corrective mechanisms feedback loops
kick in to correct the system and the
super haps have disabled these Makino
and the you know compensation that you
just mentioned it for instance is a
manifestation of that everything has
become more extreme and that's a result
of power loss so now the system has
become so skewed that the pendulum
effect to the other extreme is very
strong for instance I think Donald Trump
is an extreme example but we're seeing
the same phenomenon coming up in Europe
with lepen for instance or urban and
hungry
it's very worrisome how much do you
think about our worry about our twenty
trillion dollars in debt I worry about
it a lot also because the debt levels
worldwide have never been higher and
with financial engineering we've been
able to kind of glance over at Fabio
what is financial engineering financial
engineering is when you take debts or
could be physical things and you
transform them into security usually you
say you take subprime the subprime
crisis was an example you take all those
mortgages and then these are all papers
right it's just stuff written on papers
and you take all these papers and you
slice and dice them and you put them in
computer models and then you make it's
very difficult to explain it's
artificial construct it's all abstract
financial products isn't it
just rich people reacting all the rest
of the peoples chains yes actually I
identify this as a problem the
increasing financialization that we've
seen in the last decades
financialization in me it basically
means financial engineering which has
been fueled by debt and that leads to
the fact that after a while all this
money is shuffled around in these
transactions and only a small part goes
to the real economy what's your reaction
first let me ask you the definition of a
class trader
what's a class trader a class trader is
someone like George Soros who actually
you know belongs to this 1% class
but he comes out and criticizes it or
Paul Tudor Jones who just showed and
also the man that I Nick Khan or Nick
Hanover what do you think of those
people I mean you worked you worked a
lot it seems like in the book with
George Soros well I think many of the
super helps see what's wrong with the
system but it's also one of the key
questions I asked in the book is do they
hold the system prisoner or are they
prisoners of the system is it their
fault or is it the system's fault and
it's in the end after analysis I come to
the conclusion it's the interaction of
both but as long as these people are in
the system actually asked George Soros
once why he donates all this money why
he doesn't just change the system and he
says as long I'm trying to change the
system but but as long as it exists the
way that it does I operate within the
system you talk about George Soros in
your book and his interest in being an
intellectual writer can you tell us more
about that he wrote books and you
weren't your accidental critical of him
that he didn't he didn't the books
weren't that impressive no I cite the
Financial Times and other it isn't
that's the same thing as saying yourself
that you didn't think it was very
impressive no because I haven't read it
yeah I'm ready I mean the early examples
of his research I haven't read no I just
cited and the point why I cited is
because I say all these super ups abide
by the cult of failure they all stressed
the importance of failures because they
say these are the most formative
experiences in our lives and I give
George as an example who now is very
respected as a public intellectual and I
basically talk about his humble
beginnings and that he didn't let the
criticism beat him down but he tried all
the harder well go back to this business
of as you said the class traders seems
like they get it both ways I mean they
go out and make a lot of money billions
of dollars and then they say oh it's
horrible we have this inequality but
they go right on living in another world
and continue to make money in that world
so why should we even listen to them
well I'm not gonna make any excuses for
them I think you have a very valid point
but I still think we should listen to
them because they do understand the
system and they have a leadership
function in our society so they can make
things happen we I think it would be
foolish to completely disregard them and
also yes we could start a revolution
just solely from the bottom up but that
would probably entail with that probably
wouldn't have a spearheaded leadership
and would cause disruptions of the
system that would be uncontrolled and
could be damaging for all segments of
society most from what you know about
class traitors you have the Koch
brothers on the right supposedly George
Soros on the left supposedly is there
any difference between what they're
doing I think yes it's very different
ideologies but should one be praised and
the other be criticized I mean I
certainly think the truth is always
somewhere in the middle and I mean I
don't know the Koch brothers so well I
don't think George's as Extreme as he's
made out to be
it's always more interesting to polarize
people and you point out more extreme
things and I don't know but I think what
we should do is harvest the best ideas
and then we shouldn't just blindly
follow any of them why would somebody
say to somebody else I'm in this for the
money well probably people in finance
have to say I'm in it for the money
because when you entrust someone a
banker with your money you want him to
make money right but I think that most
of the super hubs they are not just
successful because of the money because
that doesn't give you the motivation to
go that far to the very very top and
then there are great differences in the
kind of money that they make the hedge
funders can make a couple of billion a
year and then bang ce o--'s make 20
million so there's also there the
differences are pretty great well we
have a I want to put this up on the
screen a bank CEO and they're not just
banks they are investment banks but see
what they make and these are all names
that you know Jamie Dimon 37 million
dollars in 2005
team Lloyd Blankfein of Goldman Sachs
23,000,000 James Gorman of Morgan
Stanley 21 million Michael Corbitt of
Citigroup 16 point four million well
when you see those numbers what's your
reaction I think it's too high very
clearly but the fault also lays a little
with a board the board should exert more
pressures on on CEOs and I think maybe
Jamie Dimon challenged the sport I don't
remember exactly but also shareholders
can exert more pressure and warren
buffett has been very critical and said
that the money that Wall Streeters make
is in or relation to the actual value
that they contribute do you think
shareholders really have any say about
CEOs and their their salaries
I think shareholders are becoming more
influential and also institutional
shareholders because it's not just
Cheryl Dorsey like you and I it's also
especially institutional investors who
hold large contingents of shares like
Blackrock for instance and I do think
that they're becoming more involved
because it's socially not justifiable
anymore to grant these huge compensation
packages you talked about you've been to
Davos ten times and you spend a lot of
time in the company of all these people
what's there you're you're talking about
also there aren't many women in it at
all what's their reaction to you when
they see you in a crowd well now they
kind of know me but I think initially I
mean I don't know I I don't maybe have a
little bit of a chip on my shoulder but
I feel initially I have to fight a
little harder to be taken seriously how
do you see that in a group it's very
subtle it's looks and tone of voice
that's being ignored or you know things
like that
have you been accused of that by any of
them of having a chip on your shoulder
no but I personally think I probably do
I think many women do and I have a whole
chapter dedicated to the reason why
there are so few women and finance what
would you what would you recommend to
women that are
interested in the finance world what
would you tell them to do once they try
to get into this business and do they
have any chance of doing what all these
white men have done the chances are very
slim and also if we look at women who
are very accomplished to make it to
senior positions they're usually more
accomplished better educated than men
have a better track record but they have
to fight so hard so I would say to women
if you enter this profession talk to a
lot of other women who have been there
and be aware that it's going to be it's
not going to be a walk in the park and
then at some point your career is
probably going to stall what do you
personally do and I'm jumping but what
do you personally do when somebody comes
up to you who you would categorize you
may never do this as a slimy weasel
there's got to be people and that 2,500
people to go to Davos that you might
characterize as a slimy weasel how do
you deal with them well I would avoid
try to avoid confrontation and I always
try to be professional and polite but
Larry Summers himself was basically run
out of Harvard so why should we listen
time well I said I quote him in the book
when he says to Elizabeth no yes
was it sheila bair elizabeth warren
sheila bair he said if you're part of
the system within the system you can't
criticize the system because you'll be
kicked out but when you're out of the
system you can criticize it only nobody
will listen to you and I applaud Larry
for what he said there and I can attest
to the same thing I've also spoken to
many CEOs and I think now Larry's
outside of the system and he is he
voices valid criticism and it's a very
it's a key question how should CEOs
react when they're being antagonized
blackmailed intimidated so what do you
think Donald Trump calls him into the
White House they sit around and talk for
an hour and they go out in front of a
microphone say it was great are you
asking me what they should do I'm just
asking what you think when you see that
I mean if you're if you were at home
watching television and all of a sudden
you saw these very high position CEOs
coming out and say
what a great this is great world's gonna
look good for the future we really
enjoyed our meeting with Donald Trump on
the one hand I'm disappointed on the
other hand I think it's easy to
criticize them because they're in charge
of thousands sometimes hundreds of
thousands of employees sometimes in more
than a hundred countries they have
unbelievable responsibilities and with
this president who's very unpredictable
of course they have to tread lightly
where at the outset we have no idea
where it's going so I think in the
beginning I think what they're trying to
do also this roundtable that Steve
Schwarzman is heading I think they're
trying to exert their influence so that
when Donald Trump antagonizes China or
Mexico that they're going that they're
trying to limit the damage somehow what
do you think of our new president I seem
very critically how tell us more I don't
think he has the temperament and the
qualification for the job what do you
hear people saying I'm you know among
all these CEOs in New York did you deal
with I hear them say the same thing
what's the cult of failure the cult of
failure is that we must not be afraid of
failing and I actually think it's one of
the great things of American culture
entrepreneurial culture is that people
here are allowed to fail they're not
being looked upon down upon as long as
they get up again and these super hubs
have all experienced great failures and
they've always stood up and kept on
fighting and I think that actually is I
don't regard them as role models per se
but I think that's a very good quality
to have
Alexander Alexandra wolf was here a
couple of weeks ago talking about
Silicon Valley where it's almost a very
positive thing to fail where does all
this idea that failing is good come from
your perspective on that okay I think as
everything failing is good in moderation
I don't think we should make it a cult
I think that's exaggerated because that
promotes too much risk
taking so we should try and limit the
downside somewhat but we all experience
rejection and failure even on the
smallest level and youngest age and I
think it's important to become resilient
because as Janet Yellen has also said
grit is very important in life not just
career-wise just generally even so if
the pitchforks are going to come here in
the future well what do you what do you
suggest people look for as an indication
that things are going to deteriorate
from an economic standpoint and in the
world
I think our system is very fragile and
the IMF the Bank of England the Bank for
International Settlements they have all
warned that the next financial crisis is
just around the corner and part of the
reason is because the financial industry
and politics are so intertwined and the
global debt levels and it could go very
quickly what we've seen in the past is
when there's been dramatic inflection
points like for instance the Arab Spring
or the financial crisis institutions
that are littered with world experts
like the IMF or the CIA have missed
those crises or I mentioned Ben Bernanke
at the Fed earlier they have the best
information they do have a bird's eye
view and they miss dramatic developments
so also what so I can't tell you exactly
what nobody can tell you what will
trigger a failure of our financial
system or the economy but what I can say
is that our system has become so fragile
that it becomes even more susceptible to
what's called a butterfly effect meaning
slight and remote disturbances that
could be very far away and it's this
example of the wing fly of a what's
called a wing flap of a butterfly in
Tokyo can contribute to a tornado in the
United States a month later so fragility
makes the whole system more susceptible
to these small disturbances that could
actually trigger failure but let me ask
you again though what do you think you
how will we know I mean we saw what
happened in 2008 it happened very
quickly but how do you think we'll know
when things are falling apart will it be
the stock market will it be the interest
rates help us out I mean it could be the
stock market but the stock market is
just for me basically a psychological
indicator it's a manifestation of the
herd instinct it doesn't right now it's
off the charts good but that doesn't
necessarily reflect the underlying
fundamentals so I'm a little wary of the
stock market as an indicator although it
can contribute to a self-reinforcing
downward spiral and that people panic
and then nobody lends money anymore and
then we have a bank run and then
illiquidity will leave to insolvency I
mean you know again is exacerbate bad um
developments but what I'm more concerned
about right now are the political
developments that we're seeing all over
the world so you know the instability in
the Middle East and I'm I'm just afraid
that something bad could happen there
who's Larry think Larry think has found
it found it Blackrock which is the
largest as a management company in the
world what they do they manage money
from institutional investors like
pension funds and sovereign wealth funds
and I mean in that sense basically all
our money what's he like I don't know
him very well he's very friendly he's
charming he's funny from what I can tell
and what were you doing at the time and
how does it differ what you're doing now
I was working at a at a bond shop and
that was the job that I actually had
come over to the United States for I was
their general counsel
sowhat's if you're in a bond shop what's
the what do you really have to know to
work in a bond job what kind of
education do you need well as general
counsel I worked on deals on deal
platforms so that would be the structure
the paperwork and dentures offering them
or and constructive contractual
documents subscription documents you
have to negotiate with rating agencies
you have to talk to clients you have to
go into regulatory matter
Arisa or german pension plans you know
there are legal restrictions and you
have to somehow make it come together
and make it work where did you grow up
in Germany just sort of actually much
you got buff but nobody knows that's
them and what was life like there
compared to what life is here in the
United States I come from a small town
Germany is very homogeneous that was um
yeah provincial but there was the
British forces headquarter in in my city
so I as a teenager I will go there and
play basketball and try to speak English
as best as I could and it was a little
bit of a window to the world do you
think in German or do you think in in
American or English both depends can you
go back and forth with the language just
like you did there on the phones yes I
can and I dream in both languages and
sometimes I feel that I'm not fluent and
either anymore and my english isn't
perfect I feel my German isn't perfect
anymore either
but it fends very much on the time of
the day in the shape that I'm in what is
better about the United States compared
to Germany and what is worse compared to
Germany I mean Germany in the United
States to compare those two is is really
difficult I mean the you know I love the
United States because it's a melting pot
because of its diversity I feel it
brings out the best in people it's the
highest common denominator in some sense
and that's been you know its value at
that's made it so competitive globally
all right so I don't even look at the
numbers lately I think about a sixth of
our country their origins in Germany do
you feel that when you're here do you
see people that look just like the
Germans you grew up with no not at all
but I think it's because of our history
that Germans don't really stress their
heritage it's no I don't usually notice
so how did Germans look at money
compared to the way the Americans in the
world you live in a New York City look
at money Germans are more understated
with regard to money it's something you
don't talk about I don't think as an
industry they've been very good
in managing or managing money for lack
of a better term because in in the years
before the crisis all these American
money managers would come would descend
upon Germany with their suspenders and
you know sparkly watches and sell all
this up subprime paper to Germans and
they've bought it indiscriminately which
led to the headline on the Wall Street
Journal subprime on the Rhine and with
transactions mentioned that I'd actually
worked on and people that who I knew
like I couldn't believe it reportedly
Donald Trump in his business had 300
million dollars in loans from deutsche
bank and some have written that this is
should be of concern Deutsche Bank's had
some problems what do you think well you
asked me earlier about President Trump
and I think my main concern is his
conflicts of interest and his family and
this whole kind of closed system that he
is establishing and you know my book is
about networks and super ups and I think
in his world and in Trump land networks
are becoming all the more important
because it's a it's a closed off system
in which personal relationships become
all the more important which means that
the rest of the world does not the you
know US citizens they don't have access
this book is called an international
bestseller women was at first published
and where was it published
I was published in Germany in January
2016 and it was a best-seller even a
week before it came out forward on this
book is binary on Roubini who we looked
at earlier the name of the book is super
hubs